how long did it take you to find the
thing that
uh you have fun with well i don't know
i've been a fun person since i was
pretty little so everything i've gone
through a couple periods of depression
in my life
a good reason or for uh the reason that
doesn't make any sense
yeah like some things are hard
like you go through mental transitions
in high school i was
really depressed for a year and i think
i had my first midlife crisis at 26.
i kind of thought is this all there is
like i was working at a job that i loved
and but i was going to work and all my
time was consumed
what's what's the escape out of that
depression what's the answer to is
is this all there is well
a friend of mine i asked him because he
was working his ass off i said what's
your work-life balance
like like there's you know work friends
family personal time are you bouncing in
that and he said work 80
family 20 and i try to i try to find
some time to sleep
like there's no personal time there's no
passion at a time
like you know young people are often
passionate about work so
i was certainly like that but you need
to
you need to have some space in your life
for different things
and that's that creates uh that makes
you resistant to the whole
the the dip the the deep dips
into depression kind of thing yeah well
you have to get to know yourself too
meditation helps some physical
something physically intense helps like
the weird
places your mind goes kind of thing like
and why does it happen
why do you do what you do like triggers
like the things that cause your mind to
go to different places
kind of thing or events like
you're upbringing for better or worse
whether your parents are great people or
not
you you you come into
you know adulthood with all kinds of
emotional burdens
yeah and you can see some people are so
bloody stiff and restrained and they
think
you know the world's fundamentally
negative like you maybe
you have unexplored territory yeah
or you're afraid of something uh
definitely afraid of quite a few things
then you gotta go face them like
like what's the worst thing gonna happen
you're gonna die right
like that's inevitable you might as well
get over that like a hundred percent
death rate
i know people were worried about the
virus but you know the human condition
is pretty deadly
you